all right everybody let's close out with
a story sure to make you feel warm and
fuzzy this holiday season this is what
I'm
liking so when a North Carolina
7-year-old told her dad she wanted to
start a coffee company he went all in to
help her out now two years later she is
one of the youngest CEOs I have ever
heard of she has a thriving coffee shop
and an online business selling Home
roasted beans and candles and soap made
from coffee grounds all that and she and
her dad are giving back to the community
which is incredible we have her on the
line right now along with her father
watching on
wyff4 what's up Charlie and tshane
[Music]
hey hello so Charlie what's it like
being CEO you're so young I love it
because everybody supports me and
whatever me and Dad do it's never one
single person everything we do we work
together to do a that's incredibly cool
for your family so TJ What is it like
working with her like this this I I mean
i' I've never seen anything into
comparison of watching the people that
come in and support her within this town
and this community I mean it's
absolutely amazing I mean it's literally
the epitome of the Perfection of Life of
being a dad oh oh my gosh and also
you're killing me I'm gonna cry um also
what I think is really cool is you're
also you're having this beautiful family
moment but you're giving back to the
community as well right yeah we're um
our goal this year is to help over a
thousand kids within the community so
we're a portion of our proceeds Charlie
came up with to give at least uh a
portion of the coffee that we sell
online and within our stores to help
support these kids so that that way we
can make sure that they gets toys this
year because it's just fair for kids not
to get at least one toy that's right and
I've been homeless before and been
through some pretty tough times and I
know what it's like to struggle and we
want to make sure that those kids don't
have that problem this year oh wow what
a beautiful family thank you Charlie
thank you tan I'm liking your post right
now right yes ma'am thank you all right
well that's not all you're cute little
yes ma'am I like it our season long
partner pilot pin makers of G2 the go-to
pin of the Kelly Clarkson show want to
honor truly Unstoppable people just like
the two of you so they're going to be
riding you a check for $1,000 to help
you provide more kids and more chys for
the
holiday thank you a have such a great
night y'all and thank you to all our
guests this hour Anna Wingham Nikki and
RW Garcia Addie am Alex for joining us
Lauren Darion and Oda the elf and Katie
Kaden as well y'all have a great game if
it's not try and change
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home